imagine an ultimate road trip
across the globe on a highway along the
equator
wait there there's no highway along the
equator
yet so how about we build one
what would it take to construct the
longest road on earth
how long would you spend behind the
wheel to complete this epic journey
and why would building this highway
upset environmentalists
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if we built a road around the world
there are about 64 million kilometers of
all kinds of roads around the globe but
no single highway network that can take
you from
new york directly to cape town the
hypothetical freeway that
we're about to build would easily take
you from
colombia all the way to indonesia
combine that with some of the existing
road systems
and you might just be able to drive
anywhere in the world but that would be
a
very expensive engineering achievement
because
a big part of this highway would have to
be constructed
under water
on average it takes about five to ten
years to build a highway
but we wouldn't be building just any
highway
we're aiming for a forty thousand
kilometer long
two-lane equatorial road
to construct it in about the same time
frame as a normal highway
we need to be working on different parts
of it all at the same time
our globe-spanning highway would require
about 8
million skilled workers and some 9.2
trillion dollars to build yeah
those are some whopping numbers to
consider and
what would it be like to drive on it
i'd say it's pretty cool the equator
cuts through
13 countries and three oceans
let's say you start in south america in
ecuador
and travel east through colombia to
brazil
you'd be enjoying a humid tropical
climate and
very high temperatures so make sure your
car's air conditioning is working
before you leave for the trip
you'd be passing over mountains and the
amazon river
and if you decided to go for a
refreshing swim remember that the
amazon's full of bloodthirsty piranhas
waiting to eat you in a matter of
minutes
just joking piranhas are actually calm
scavengers so
you can go for a swim at your own risk
your amazonian adventures would just be
the beginning
you would soon reach the atlantic coast
of brazil and you'd be about to
enter the first underwater stretch
the great atlantic tunnel and the view
here is
rather dull ah
finally there's land
after days of travel you would make it
to africa
you'd be driving through the savannas
swamps and
dense rainforest of gabon and congo
and into the deserts of kenya and
somalia
on your way you might see elephants
gorillas
buffaloes and leopards and
that would make the long trip through
the tunnel kind of worth it
but then you run out of land and you
enter another underwater tunnel this
time
it's the great indian tunnel
hmm oh i see land again
it's indonesia with its 17
000 islands scattered around the equator
you'd be driving through a series of
short tunnels to cross from
one island to another and every time you
got back on land
the scenery would be majestic
volcanic landscapes rice fields tropical
rainforests
i bet you could use a day at the beach
after such a long drive
okay it's time to move on to the next
tunnel
the great pacific tunnel
is it just me or is this one like three
times longer
uh no this is the longest underwater
stretch of the entire trip
and by the end of it you'd have a little
bonus in the form of
the last exciting spot of the highway
the galapagos islands
a showcase of evolution where the most
unusual forms of life
are thriving in the wild a feast for the
eyes after
that long drive then you would drive
a little further through one last short
underwater tunnel
and end up right where you started in
ecuador
hey congratulations you made a road trip
around the globe traveling at 100
kilometers per hour
you'd spend some 400 hours or
about 17 days at the wheel
12 of those days you'd be stuck inside a
tunnel under the ocean
with some breaks for the night rest and
some time to enjoy the sights the entire
travel time
would add up to at least two months
hope you can afford such a long vacation
but
as much fun as this idea sounds it would
be
an enormous hit on the planet the
construction of the highway
itself would disrupt ecosystems both
on land and in the ocean on top of that
during this epic trip your car would
emit almost
twice as much carbon dioxide as the
average car
does in a year looks like we'll never
see a highway like that
running along the equator maybe
we could start building flying cars that
would require
a different type of highway altogether
but that's a story for another
what if